juste trois points plutôt positifs de
traitement c'est-à-dire parce que là on
a fait le constat le diagnostic moi
j'aimerais qui est trois points sur le
traitement qu'on pourrait admettre en
œuvre autour de l'humanité autour de la
proximité autour de la gouvernance je
vais commencer par le dernier parce
qu'on a bien vu que l'administration
c'était un vrai problème et que la
gouvernance c'est la première réforme à
faire c'est ce qui pose problème à
l'hôpital c'est cette gouvernance et
au-delà de l'hôpital je pense que c'est
dans tout le système de santé HPST ça a
été un peu le point d'orgue mais ça fait
des années qu'il y a ce glissement là
avec finalement on s'est trompé
d'objectifs dans ce pays on a dit on va
faire des économies et après on va
soigner donc on a mis des gestionnaires
et puis après on a mis les soignants
alors qu'on doit renverser le paradigme
on doit d'abord soigner soigner mieux
avec peut-être moins de moyens ou en
tout cas une meilleure rationalisation
des moyens mais donc du coup faut mettre
des soignants aux manettes c'est juste
intolérable quand un collègue de Nicole
Michael chef de service de chirurgie
se voit par un petit directeur je dis
pardon petit parce que jeune jeune Frey
moulu de Sciences Po il fait l'école de
Rennes et il va voir un Pupa chez il lui
dit bah voilà professeur vous aviez
trois types de pinces maintenant pour
repérer les petites les grandes et les
moyennes il faut choisir parce qu'on a
passé un marché maintenant il faut
choisir un seul type de pince et vous
vous n'avez pas le choix globalement et
vous devez choisir un type de pince et
on voit bien que tout ça c'est au
détriment des malades à la clé parce que
c'est des malades qui souffrent plus et
que des torakotomie par exemple ou une
ouverture qui est plus grande et donc du
coup des coûts pour la structure ou pour
la société en tout cas plus importante
donc on voit bien qu'on est sur une
logique de court terme et pas du tout
sur une logique de moyens et de long
terme
[Musique]